ماذا تقصد بمشروع
الامامه الحقيقه كلمه
الامامه كلمه يعني ممتده
جذورها مع ماساه التاريخ العربي والاسلامي
طوال 14 قرن وكما قال الامام
الشهرستاني ما سل سيف ولا سفك دم في مساله
دينيه كالاما في الملل والنحل في المحل
نعم هي اس البلاء بالنسبه لنا في اليمن
هذا المشروع الذي
قام
على مبدا توظيف ديني لمساله سلطه وحكم
لطموح سياسي لطموح سياسي نعم اذا الامامه
بصفه عامه المقصود بها هو حكم اليمن او
حكم عموم المسلمين ا من جانب ا يعني اسره
او من جانب فئه تعتقد انها الاجدر بحكم
المسلمين مظبوط يا معال الدكتور هذا ه هذا
هذا صحيح وتم
تاويل ايات في كتاب الله وتم نسب احاديث
نسبت للرسول عليه الصلاه
والسلام لا تتفق مع جوهر الدين
وحقيقته القائم على الحريه وعدم التمييز
العنصري طيب هنرجع لده لكن مبدئيا من يمثل
مشروع الامامه في الوقت الحالي في اليمن
في الوقت الحالي يمثلها المشروع الحوثي
الذي انقلب على مشروع الدوله الاتحاديه
يوم 21 سبتمبر وهذا 21 سبتمبر ايه 2014
2014 نعم وهم اختاروا الشهر واليوم
ليعلنوا عوده مشروع الامامه التي تم
القضاء عليه بقيام الجمهوريه العربيه
اليمنيه في 26 سبتمبر
1922 لان يوم 21 سبتمبر هو اليوم الذي تم
تنصيب الامام محمد الناصر الذي تلقب
بالناصر محمد البدر بدلا المنصور محمد
البدر بدلا عن ابيه الناصر احمد يحيى حميد
الدين الذي توفى في 19 سبتمبر 62 الحوثين
هم اسره تنتمي الى ا يعني بدر الدين
الحوثي اللي هو كان مرجع لما يطلق عليه
تجاوزا الزيديه لكن هذه بنفصل المساله هذه
هو يعني متاثر
بال الفرقه الجاروديه ومتاثر بولايه
الفقيه في ايران وعاش في ايران واولاده
حسين بدر الدين الحوثي وعبد الملك الحوثي
القائم الان يعني وهم نسبا الى حوث منطقه
في عمران اسمها حوث لكنه عمران محافظه
يمنيه في الشمال في الشمال يعني قريب من
صنعاء وانتقلوا الى صعده وعاشوا في صعده
فبالتالي هم الان يعني يمثلوا هذا المشروع
الامامي الجارودي المرتبط بمشروع ولايه
الفقيه في ايران طيب طبعا هنرجع الى
الجاروديه والزيديه والاثنى عشريه الى
اخره لكن الاول هي
اسره كما فهمت هي اسره بتنتمي الى الاسياد
او الى الاشراف يعني هم من بني هاشم من
اسره الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام هذا
الكلام مضبوط هذا الكلام ما يقال لكن يا
اخي الكريم الاشكاليه اليوم كما قلت لك
يجب تصحيح هذا المفهوم الذي نكل بالامه
ونكب
الامه في واقعنا اليمني لو تشوف الان في
هذه الفتره في هذه الحرب من 2014 الى
اليوم كم ضحايا سفكت علشان هذا المصطلح هم
حقيقه اولاد علي بن ابي طالب و ليسوا
اولاد محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام صحيح
وهرجع لده مره ثانيه بس استاذنك ما
يقولونه الان انه الاسره الحوثيه هي واحده
من العائلات الهاشميه اللي بتستمر نفوذها
السياسي والديني من نسبها الى الرسول
مظبوط يا معال الدكتور نعم طيب تمام اذا
هي مجرد
اسره ليه بركز على كده عشان السؤال دايما
لمن يتابع اليمن على الاقل من الخارج من
اين تاتي هذه الاسره اسره يعني عائله من
اين تاتي هذه العائله التي تعيش الان في
صعدا بكل هذه القوه والقدره بحيث تكون
قادره على ان تقود مشروع وتقود
تجيش من يقاتل حولها لعده سنوات لاكثر من
سبع او ثمان سنوات هذا في هنا عوامل
داخليه وعوامل خارجيه مؤثره في الموضوع
العوامل الداخليه هي البيئه الج رافيه
للمنطقه التي انطلقت منها الامامه الحوثيه
اليوم من صعدا اللي كانت تمثل يعني مركز
الزيديه الذي اتت الى اليمن وهي هادو في
الاساس لانه نفصل بعدين الفرق ما بين
الزيديه والهاديه
فبالتالي هذه البيئه الدينيه مهدت الارضيه
التي تقوم عليها هذه الاسره لتؤسس مشروعها
السياسي لانه الحضن الديني والمذهبي
والطائفي موجود العوامل الخارجيه
التواصل مع المشروع الايراني في المنطقه
ومشروع تصدير الثوره الايرانيه التقت هذه
العوامل كلها بوجود مرجعيه دينيه هادو
يعني مثلها ا بدر الدين الحوثي ل ايجاد
هذا المشروع في مك اذا ارضيه دينيه وارضيه
جغرافيه بسكانها وارضيه يعني داعمه بشيعه
ايران وشيعه المنطقه العربيه والخليج اذا
حضرتك بتقول انه هذه الاسره بتستمر قوتها
من التقائها مع المشروع الايراني الذي
يدعمها واحد اثنين البيئه الجغرافيا تحرك
ركزت على طبيعه السكان اللي هي حاضنه
تحتضن هذه الافكار في عدد كبير من
اليمنيين على الاقل في هذه المنطقه يؤمن
بفكره الامامه وحق ال البيت في الحكم كما
فهمت من كلام حضرتك وا الحوثي واحد من هذه
الاسر الاسر ولا انا فهمت غلط لا لا نعم
لانه من حق اي انسان عالم مجتهد قادر ان
يخرج مطالبا بالامامه هذه نظريه الخروج
نظريه الخروج في في اي فقه وفق وفقا للفقه
الزيدي والهدوء تمام هذه في نظريه الخروج
اي انسان يرى في نفسه القدره والاجتهاد
والعلم ان يخرج حتى في بعض الفترات
التاريخيه كان يخرج اكثر من امام من نفس
الاسره وابناء عمه واحده ولهذا هذا الصراع
الامامه من من دخلت اليمن يعني عام 282
للهجره اخرجت اليمن من دوره الحضاري
والتاريخي ودخل في سلسله من الحرو
ما بين امام يعلن قيامه وامام يعلن خروجه
فنظر الخروج هي هذه تمام تمام اذا فاحنا
حتى ناتي الى كل هذه التفاصيل المهمه جدا
اسره الحوثي الاساس في قوتها ان هي بتعتمد
على
شرعيه او على حقها من وجهه نظرها ومن وجهه
نظر انصارها في ان تحكم اليمن بل وتحكم
المسلمين لانهم من من بني هاشم ومن اسره
الرسول ولهم الحق في ان يحكموا مضبوط معي
الدكتور نعم ومعنى ذلك ان هناك اسر اخرى
او عائلات او قبائل تتضامن مع هذه الفكره
او تلتقي مصالحها مع هذه الفكره صحيح طيب
هو السؤال قبل ما ناتي الى الحوثييين مره
اخرى بما ان هم راس هذا المشروع هو في اصل
هم لما بقطع النظر انه واضح ان حضرتك
تعارض هذا المشروع لكن هم بصوه ازاي في
الفكر الاسلامي وبيق نعوا بجم كثيره من
المسلمين باي نصوص يعني جذر الفكره جاي
منين هو اعتمد على شرعيه فقهيه في الين
الاسلام قامت عليها مفهوم الامامه وقامت
على اسس الوصيه والولايه
والامامه
الامامه في قريش مبدا واحد الامامه في ال
البيت اللي هم
يعني ابناء علي وبنيه الامامه في البطنين
حصروتي
انا اقول فقهيه وليست دينيه لانها تتعارض
مع نصوص الدين الذي هو وحي من الله بلغه
رسوله عليه الصلاه والسلام فالله ليس
عنصريا والاسلام ليس دين عنصري دين
للعالمين للانس والجن وللناس كافه لا يمكن
ان يكون لقريش او لبني هاشم او لاهل البيت
وهذه
بفصلها جذورها و خروجها عن عن الدين اذا
هذه الاسس الشرعيه لانه كان زمان شرعيه
السلطه لا تاتي من البيان رقم واحد كما في
تاريخنا المعاصر نحن مع الانقلابات
العسكريه نعم والثورات يصدر لك بيان رقم
واحد واكتسب شرعيته كانت الشرعيه في تلك
الفتره قائمه على الدين اه والصراع
العصبيه داخل بطون قريش نفسها ما بين
الامويين
والعباسيين
والهاشميين والعلويين
والطالبية والسلام وتاويل ايات في كتاب
الله لا علاقه لها بهذه المفاهيم كلها
وهذه يحتاج توضيح وتفصيل ليعرف الناس مدى
هذا الخلل الذي ادخل الامه وادخل اليمن
اليوم في هذه الازمه التي نعيشها طب نعود
الاول الى منطقهم قبل نقد منطقهم هم
بيقولوا
ا نحن اولى بحكم اليمن وحكم المسلمين
لاننا من بني هاشم واننا اسره هاشميه
وبالتالي وفقا ل اسانيد بيستنوا اليها هم
اولى بحكم المسلمين اهم هذه الاسانيد
باختصار شديد زي ايه شوف اخي الكريم هنا
انا
اديك القسم يرد على هذا السؤال باختصار
هذا قسم الولاء يعني في الكليات العسكريه
والمليشيات وطلبه المدارس في اين بقى في
الاماكن التي يسيطر عليها الحثي تسيطر
عليها الانقلاب المليشيا الحوثي قول القسم
هذا
اللهم انا نتولاه ونتولى رسولك ونتولى
الامام علي شوف من الله للرسول للامام علي
ونتولى من امرتنا امر من الله صادر لهم
بتوليه سيدي ومولاي عبد الملك بدر الدين
الحوثي شوف اللهم انا نبرا من عدوك وعدو
نبيك وعدو الامام علي وعدو من امرت
بتولي سيدي ومولاي عبد الملك الحوثي هذا
القسم يؤصل لك البعد الديني اللي قام
بالتسلسل الولايه والوصيه من الله للرسول
لعلي لبنيه والتسلسل ماشي في النسل حتى
وصل الى عبد الملك الحوثي اليوم ال يعني
شرعيه من اين جاؤوا بفكره
ان احفاد الرسول بقطع النظر انه كلام
يحتاج الى نقد يعني من وجهه نظر حضرتك ومن
اخرين من اين جاؤوا بهذه الشرعيه هل
الرسول قال انه الشرعيه يجب ان تكون في
علي بن ابي طالب واولاده مستحيل ان يكون
الرسول قاله لكن كما قلت لك كان تاليف
لمشروع كان رواه الاحاديث نسب لهذا لانه
الرسول عليه الصلاه وسلم مات ولم يوصي
احدا بالحكم من بعده لا علي ولا غيره
ولهذا هذا حدثت حادثه السقيفه الذي اجمع
الناس عليها كلها والحوار الذي حصل ما بين
المهاجرين
والانصار يعني وكل يدعي ان يكون له دور
يعني الى ان وصل الامر الى منا امير ومنكم
امير في الحادثه المشهوره بتتكلم عن سقفه
الحث سقيفه بني سعده اه بعد وفاه الرسول
بعد وفاه الرسول مباشره نعم وهم يناقشوا
من الخليفه الانصار يقولوا نحن والمهاجرين
يقولوا نحن وكان
كل ما قدم ليست نصوص دينيه كان الانصار
يقولوا ايش اللي قدموا لمحمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام ش قدموا لهذا الدين يعني من نصره
ومن ايواه والى خلافه وكانك تقدم برنامج
سياسي كما يقال اليوم قدارت جدارتك في
الاحقيه المهاجرين ايضا نفس الشيء نحن اول
من اسلم مهاجر وعان وقدم وهكذا اذا لو
كانت هذه النصوص التي اتت في مرحله
التدوين سواء كانت نصا بوصيه او بحديث او
لما كان حصل هذا الخلاف بين المهاجرين
والانصار يعني في تلك الفتره اذا هذه اتت
بها عصر التدوين ليشرع كما يحصل اليوم كل
من يريد ان ان يدعم قضيته يؤلف لها الادله
و وما هي الادله من وجهه نظ الحرك التي
الفوها لان هم بيقولوا ما الفناها هذه
احاديث موجوده ونصوص وبيست اليها بقطع
النظر عن عدم اتفاق حضرتك مع هذه الادله
ما هي الادله التي يسوقونها لدعم شرعيتهم
احاديث الوصيه الوصيه والولايه في في حديث
الغدير يعني من كنت مولاه فعلي مولاه
وعشان كده الاهتمام بالغدير وال نبدا
بالوصيه الاول حديث الوصيه خلاصته ايه
خلاصته انه هنالك وصيه من الله للرسول
لعلي وابنائه من فاطمه الحسن والحسين
وبنيهم بانهم هم يعني يتولوا يعني السلطه
الدينيه والسلطه السياسيه وهذه هي من
الاسرائيليات التي نقلت من ملوك اليهود
الذي يعني يرث
كان سلطه النبوه وسلطه الملك زي سليمان
وداؤود والى اخره لكن في دين الاسلام
الخاتم كرساله للعالمين لا وجود للافضل
بين البشر كلهم الناس سواسيه يعني الايه
اللي تخاطب الناس يعني انه خلقهم الله
شعوبا وقبائل ليتعارفوا
والتكريم عند الله وعند رسوله عليه الصلاه
والسلام قائم وفقا للوح على التقوى وليس
على النسب هذا نمره واحد بس هو نمره واحد
في نقد الفكره اللي حضرتك حريص عليها وانا
كمان حريص عليها ولكن الاول انا عاوز افهم
الفكره هم بيقولوا ان هناك وصيه الوصيه دي
وفقا لمنطق الذي ت اختلفوا معهم فيه ما هي
الوصيه يعني هل في نص مثلا بيقول وفقا لهم
ان هناك وصيه من الله الى الرسول الى علي
وابنائه في الحكم يعني نص الحديث مثلا
بيقول ايه ا هم نصوص في احاديث تقول
متعدده تقول هذا الكلام ونصوص في احاديث
الامامه تقول هذا الكلام واشهرها حديث
الامامه في قريش الامامه في قريش ولكن ليس
في بني هاشم هم في قريش ثم قالوا غره قريش
بني هاشم وتسلسله احاديث تؤيد هذه الدلاله
وهذا المعنى فبت وما هو غدير خم غدير خهم
هذا هو الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام
اثناء عودته من حقه الوداع يعني مر على
الغدير خم غدير يعني يعني مكان ما يعني في
الطريق ورويا عنه انه قال هذا الحديث من
كنت مولاه فعلي مولاه هذا من ضمن ي مجموعه
من
الاحاديث بتسمى بحديث الوصيه وحديث غدير
خم من كنت مولاه فعلي مولاه اجمالي هذه
الاحاديث كلها بيستن
اليها اصحاب التيار السياسي في بني هاشم
او ما يسمى بالهاشميه السياسيه مضبوط معال
الدكتور نعم